good morning everyone welcome to radio
District council's planning committee
um I will now ask the government officer
to read out the domestic arrangements
and the fire regulations thank you
Claire
thank you chair
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use please do not
interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversations whilst others are
speaking if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave please ensure your mobile
phones are on silent or switched off and
that your laptop is also switched to
xylem
we will be using the e-voting for this
meeting on the modern gov app so please
give members make sure they are logged
in and ready to use the app
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being recorded by
entering this meeting as a speaker you
are also consenting to be recorded by
the council under the possible use of
those sound recordings for webcasting
and training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
if you hear the fire alarm leave the
building immediately via fire exit and
make your way to the assembly ground
which is Ipswich Town Football ground
follow the science directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium if you're in the
atrium at the time of the alarm follow
the signs for the nearest fire exit
use the stairs not the lifts and do not
re-enter the building until told it's
safe to do so thank you Jack thank you
Claire introductions today we have the
area planning manager Mark Russell with
us
our legal advisor today is
Dean
um case of President development
Samantha Summers and government officer
you've already met his Claire Philpot
can I move to the agenda
do you have any apologies for absence
interests another registerable or
non-registerable interests by members
are there any to declare
no thank you
moving on confirmation of the minutes of
the meeting held on the 19th of October
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
no in that case could I have a proposer
to accept the minutes
Council Osborne eventually Hinton
secondary
foreign
thank you chair that vote is now
progress members
councilor beer can I take your oh thank
you and councilman Coral oh thank you
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for on one abstention that's
carried thank you
moving on
notification of petitions
site inspections
thank you we'll move into the schedule
of planning applications the first one
we have to consider
is DC 22
02336 Chilton Woods mixed development to
north of Woodall Business Park
we've got a case-ups of sun give us an
introduction Sam over to you thank you
good morning this application seeks
Reserve matters for layout appearance
scale and landscaping for phase two of
the children Woods development
application comes to committee because
it is a major development of two
outline permission was granted for
children Woods in 2018
for the erection of up to 1150 dwellings
15 hectares of Employment Development
which included a household waste site
Recycling Center District heating energy
center a Village Center retail space
Village Hall workspace primary school
preschool and car parking also included
is the vehicular access points
sustainable transport links community
Woodland open space sustainable drainage
Sports Pavilion playing fields
allotments and Associated ancillary
works
the children would cite is to the north
of Sudbury
the plan shows the extent of the
residential development site of 1150
dwellings which Taylor wimpey has
ownership of
major infrastructure Works have been
granted permission for the distributor
Road and drainage
the phase one residential development of
the scheme has been granted permission
for 200 dwellings
the Primary School site
which is located
just here
um is under a different ownership and
we'll come forward at a different phase
of development
the red line shows uh the site that
we're looking at today
which is for 242 dwellings
this plan shows the application site of
phase two in relation to the existing
development over Aubry Drive which is
down here
uh Hawkins Road
Acton Lane
and mount Batten road which is okay
um also Woodhall Business Park
uh lays in this area here
this plan also shows the phase one
development which was uh both sides of
Acton Lane so a smaller site just here
and then the larger site just here and
this is the primary School site that
will come forward later
there is little in the way of
constraints for the phase two
development site apart from a public
right-of-way which runs along the
western boundary of the site which you
can just see here
this plan shows the contour lines of the
site
a public right-of-way which is this dark
line that runs down here
uh the Primary School site just here
phase one development that's being
constructed at the moment just here
um and Acton Lane which cuts through uh
Chilton Woods development here
um this area is to be pedestrianized
members might remember that from the
phase one application
the old Middle School site that's
actually been demolished now
that was accessed off Acton Lane is this
here just to give you a bit of context
of where the site is
the L-shaped layout of the site there
are green areas all around the edges of
the site to the western boundary
Southern
and then part of this eastern boundary
here
those green areas include the drainage
basins and swales for the surface water
drainage of the site
an area of open space is to the
northeastern corner of the site just
here
this here is the distributor road which
already has a planning permission
two Junctions are proposed from this
distributor Road for phase two one just
here
and the other one here
further green areas within the site are
a dual step green area in the center of
this residential area just here
and also the cycle link
that runs through here which links the
other phases of development to the
Primary School site
public right-of-way along the western
boundary is included within this green
area here
this plan shows the layout of the roads
on the site the dark gray areas are the
roads to be adopted and then the brown
areas are the private drives
there are two uh distinct areas within
the site itself each serve from one of
those two
access points so there's no crossing
over between the two and this ease is
getting around the site and makes it
much easier for visitors and delivery
drivers Etc to find their way around
this blue line here shows uh the cycle
way
there are several types of parking on
the site the yellow
shows the courtyard parking which serves
the apartment blocks and some of the
houses that are forward-facing frontages
onto the public open space areas
this creates a Pleasant area that's
fluttered with vehicles and also enables
lots of lovely natural surveillance of
those public areas without any
interference from vehicles
the pink areas show the on-plot parking
and the orange ones are the garages
blue is allocated Frontage parking
and the pale green is non-allocated
Courtyard parking
pale blue are disabled parking spaces
which relate to the apartment blocks
there's three disabled flats that are
proposed for this development
and each with one parking space
the visitor parking is shown in green
and the red shows extra parking for the
four and five bedroom dwellings where
there is a bit of an issue with a triple
tandem parking so what's happened is
there's garages with two parking spaces
in front
but because that's quite difficult for
people to maneuver in and out if there's
several people wanting to go out at the
same time or different times and they're
not parked in the correct order on
street parking is provided uh
Suffolk County Council highways
they do not like triple tandem parking
however because there's very few of
these and on-street parking has been
provided they have lifted their
objection to the object to the uh the
triple tandem parking
all of the dwellings will have electric
vehicle charging points
there are two important documents for
children with specific to Chilton Woods
along with the MPP open our own policies
um one of these is the height parameter
plan which shows
which areas should be a maximum height
levels
with this site
there's actually two
so this beige area
covers most of the site and that relates
to a 10.8 meter height restriction
this beige colored area just here
is allowed to go up to 12 meters
so the northern part of the phase 2
development just Falls within this area
here so the buildings are slightly
higher than the rest of the development
which was within this other area the
lower level of 10 point
s so this is the massing plan showing
you uh the heights of the buildings on
site
so the dark red ones just here those two
buildings they are apartment blocks
which are three stories high
um
the dark orange ones
which there is another
slightly uh reduced height apartment
block just here
um
they're two and a half stories high and
then the majority of the buildings on
the site shown in yellow are two-story
dwellings
all of the buildings uh fit within those
High parameter restrictions that were
agreed as part of the discharge of
conditions of the outline permission
the unit mix on the site is considered
to be good there's 36 one and two
bedroom apartments
six one bedroom coach houses which will
be for private use not affordable 66
two-bed units 103 beds 34 beds and only
five sorry only four five bed dwellings
on this particular phase
a total of 72 affordable units are to be
provided on the site these are pepper
potted around the site
yellow shows the market housing
purple or the affordable rent and the
blue is the shared ownership homes
there's 36 one and two bedroom
apartments that are for affordable rent
18 of the houses are affordable rent and
18 of the shared ownership are
sorry 18 are shared ownership properties
three of the apartments are wheelchair
friendly units the outline planning
permission secured 25 affordable housing
over the entire site phase one actually
secured quite a high a high percentage
at 42.5 affordable units on the 200
homes that were provided
um this one phase two comes out at 30
percent
um so the two sides together so far are
providing 35.5 affordable housing which
is ten and a half percent more than is
actually agreed by the section 106.
the other important document specific to
Chilton Woods is the design code that
was required by condition on the outline
permission so
may remember that document coming
forward to committee at the time of the
phase one development
members resolved to accept the 140 page
document that had been out to public
consultation
and the D and the condition was
discharge which means that all further
phases have to refer to this document
when uh
when it's being designed
um
both by the developer but also by us the
planning committee
the document is to be used for all
future residential development or on
site to ensure that the development is
sensitively designed to its surroundings
and broken up into character areas
phase two has four different character
types within the site
to the norm
marked with the orange color
The Village Green area
in the center of the site
sort of marked with that beigey color
that's the residential neighborhood
character area
around the boundaries
you can see the green
and that is Parkside and linear green
linkages
and to the south east corner just here
it's a very small area shown in pink
that's actually the Acton Lane character
area
design code describes what each
character area should include such as
the types of dwellings materials
planting boundary treatments and
surfacing materials
the presentation will now go through the
character areas with extracts from the
design code and also some Street Scenes
to show the build types materials and
spacing of the dwellings proposed
I haven't actually included any specific
house types we would have gone well over
a hundred slides for you to view today
if I had included all of those so I
thought the Street Scenes would be a
more helpful way of showing you and
giving you a flavor of the different
house types that have been proposed
um this is the Village Green area so
that section right in the north of the
site
the materials for that area are to be
the tote the darker tones so red brick
some weatherboarding those type of
materials that you can see on that slide
the area that has the maximum height uh
to 12 meters for dwellings
this allows for the taller apartment
blocks at the three-story level
landscape detailing includes quite
formal materials that are attractive in
that green area facing on to that public
open space
this is a sample of the type of planting
that would be suitable in the area so
quite formal lovely big natural trees
moving on to some of the street scene uh
it's here actually shows that Frontage
that
that faces onto this public open space
just here so you've got that three-story
apartment block just here and some two
and a half story semi detached dwellings
this is the residential neighborhood
area this is a much higher density build
area the materials are lighter in tone
with the use of render and some buff
brute as well as maybe some of the Reds
mixed in there as well
houses in this character area range from
two to two and a half stories in height
all right
also included in this area are the coach
houses
um that are above garages so apartments
above garages and also these
drive-throughs to uh the parking uh
Courtyards to the rear of some of the
properties
planting in residential neighborhoods uh
will be more ornamental and colorful to
lift the area visually
the use of close-boarded fencing is
necessary to protect the privacy in the
higher density areas of the site metal
railings are an attractive feature that
help to maintain an open feeling to the
frontages
this street street scene shows that the
dwellings along the eastern boundary
with the Primary School site and phase
one
you can see the third slightly lesser in
height uh apartment block just here
and you can see this use of render to
help lighten the area
this is the street scene that faces onto
the cycleway link
between the Village Green area and the
residential neighborhood area
there's a variety in the house types and
the materials and also the color of the
render
this helps to give Variety in a high
density build area
this is another residential street
showing the variety of the house types
this is the street scene from one of the
two access points so as you come into
the development itself
also showing more variety in the house
types and materials
moving on to the Acton Lane character
area this is the smallest area on the
site houses in this area tend to be the
larger four and five bedroomed units
the lighter colored materials are used
in this area
again attractive ornamental shrubs and
trees that are used in this area
the home the homes in this area face
onto Acton Lane with a wide area of
green between phase two and Acton Lane
itself rustic post and rail fencing is
used to keep this area open and
welcoming
this is the street scene looking onto
the green area which includes a Swale
for drainage
natural surveillance of this area is
quite important because of the water
risk
the final character area is the Parkside
and linear green linkages
as there is more space in this area the
dwellings are finished and the darker
tones again
dwellings in this character area face
towards the public open space to give
natural surveillance to areas of child
play and also the drainage
this also gives it an attractive
Viewpoint when looking from the public
spaces back towards the development
itself
or tree planting is used in this area
along with some ornamental hedging
knee rails are to be used to separate
spaces in this area
seen in the southwestern corner
Corner a couple of cgis have been
produced to show what the development is
likely to look like when it's built out
the first one is the Parkside and linear
green linkages in the south of the site
and this second one is those tall
apartment blocks in the north of the
site in the Village Green area
um
which Overlook that green space
these are sample materials taken from
the design code and show the lighter
tones and darker tones
specific brick and roof tiles are not
mentioned in the design code but the
samples give a good indication of what
should be used and where
generally speaking the darker tones are
used in the less dense areas of the site
where there is more light and space
lighter tones are used in the more dense
area so that the buildings do not become
overbearing to the residents
moving on to the Landscaping which is
the final of the reserve matters today
50 percent of the total area of Chilton
Woods is to be public open space as well
as the community Woodland and sports
field each phase of development that
comes forward will also have its own
public open space
they used to has four separate areas
first
is up in the north just here
second is this
is the cycle way
that links through to phase one and the
Primary School site and then we'll also
link to the other phases of development
third is a small doorstep green area in
the center of the residential area here
and the fourth is this very wide swathe
of a green area around the edges of the
site
this includes the public right-of-way
from mountbatten Road along that western
boundary
and follows up
the area includes several uh
drainage areas swales and attenuation
basins all around this green area here
there's also to be some Street
trees provided within the built up areas
to help soften the hard landscaping and
to encourage Wildlife into the center
this is the northern section of the site
showing the tree planting to this public
green area just here
Cycle Way is shown
linking through here
the public right-of-way runs along this
western boundary
and becomes part of the cycleway just
okay
the children's play area is located in
this area here
which will sit between these two and
phase three
the play area includes seesaw slide
balance beam Stepping Stones climbing
frame a rope walk and natural mounds and
stones
moving south along the western boundary
the drainage features and the tree
planting and also the footpath linking
the bit of historians is all shown on
this plan
the central doorstep green area
just in the middle here
also shows its planting
this is the southern part of the site
the deeper drainage basins will have
rustic knee rails around them
to stop the small children from
accidentally falling into them if there
happens to be a flood event
swales are left open as these are quite
shallow dips and can be used for as play
areas for children
the green areas are protected by
bollards or fencing to ensure that
Vehicles do not drive onto them
there is an existing play area for the
residents of mountbatten Road just in
this area here and there is a path that
runs through this section which links
the two developments together
which it encourages interaction between
new and existing residents
this is the eastern boundary uh with
Acton Lane Acton Lane is just here
um in this area there's a footpath that
runs along here and then out onto the
main distributor Road rather than onto
Acton Lane itself
this slide shows some of the examples of
drainage uh and swales on on other sites
just to give you an idea of what they
might be planted with and what they
might be looking
so as you can see they are quite shallow
they're generally dry unless there's a
flood event and normally planted with
wildflowers to make an attractive
feature for ecology
in terms of ecology Hedgehog fencing
will be provided across the site
Swift boxes are built into the dwellings
themselves
and much of the planting will be wild
flowers
in the public open space areas
particularly in the drainage areas
also included for Ecology are bat boxes
B bricks
I'll go back so you can see a pretty
picture
members today are deciding the reserve
matters for phase two so that's layout
appearance scale and Landscaping
the recommendation of offices is to
approve with a condition to agree the
minor outstanding Landscaping concerns
that are in your papers
also the developer has asked that
materials be conditioned at the moment
Taylor wimpier finding it quite
difficult to get hold of materials so if
we use a specific brick or roof tile
they have to come back in all the time
to actually get it changed so they would
find it helpful if we could have a
condition just to say that we can agree
materials in writing
thank you members
thank you Samantha
any questions for the officer
Council beer
or three
um
um You referred to one bad coach
dwellings
I don't know what that is perhaps is
that like a bed set
yeah so in this case it's where you have
garages and then a platter above the
garage
and there's six of those actually on the
site and they're just single yeah on
bedroom units yeah and they're all for
they're for private Market housing
sounds a good idea
um triple Park and how many of those
have we got because Wells County say
they're going to bend the rules on this
they're really still not acceptable
uh yeah there's very few I I think it's
six but the developer might be able to
answer that question
um
very soon yeah very few out of 242
dwellings thank you um now I notice
um quite a lot of
um comments was made to posts and
barriers to stop people Park and where
they shouldn't be on the verges and
edges
can you show me that most of the housing
properties
do their boundary does go up to a solid
either footpath in front or road in
front there's no grass verges in front
of those properties where people can end
up parking and make the mess of yeah so
apart from the houses that face onto
those green areas which do have the um
the meal
knee-high railings around them I believe
that in the residential areas nearly all
of it will be pavement and then Road
thank you only a couple more
um the who will look after those
barriers and posts in 10 years Towing
because I know from other states we've
been on they get knocked down they rot
all sorts of things happen and nobody
wants to pick up the bill
so who is going to be responsible
eventually down the road it will depend
who takes on the maintenance so either
it could be Parish Council or it could
be
District Council or indeed it could be a
private management company it depends
how the developer works that out so so
just to be clear then there will be some
Authority who will be responsible to do
The Replacements in the future yes
because quite often when we've gone back
10 years later but it is on Old sites
they've over disappeared and we can't
get anyone to do any of the work and it
becomes a mess so that's good my final
point then is
um oh I'm sorry I've got two round by
the school can we have plan number 12 or
14 up
um
I'm just concerned
does the properties or this particular
site border up to the school or is there
a Road between there
because
as you know usually we create these
schools on these Estates and in the past
they get a chopper block with traffic
and people taking the children to school
in cars and what have you now
um it looked rather tight on on the
plans as though there was no spaces
there
um and I wanted to know whether you know
we could end up taking our children to
school behind the school and parking
somewhere there and going through the
hedge or a footpath
yeah go to 12 I think that might show up
better
I think up there the school is in the
second bit isn't it there yeah and now
across the road they are uh you've got
barriers on that I saw that this is
distributor road yeah can they all Park
on there because you know as well as I
do Mr chairman that
um where there's a school if there's a
road that they can park on that will get
Chopper block between ten to nine ten
past nine in the morning
so is there any provisions there for
this
is that going to be the main entrance to
the school or will it be on the other
side we don't know that yet I don't know
that yet no sorry
um so the major infrastructure Works
came forward
right at the start before the phase one
development came through I'm not sure
what was actually agreed with that but
because it's the main distributor Road I
would assume that it would have
um some sort of parking restriction on
their double yellow lines or something
but I'm not too sure of the deal that
can take two years to get but so I can
see we could have problems there I think
it's something we need to watch yeah so
the developer might be able to answer
that question for you I wasn't involved
with that particular application so I
don't know the detail of it and I'll ask
him that and finally
um do have we heard any comments on the
local Ward members councilor Creswell
councilor Jan Osborne
I can answer that we have a statement
from councilor John Osborne to redo
thank you
Council Jameson
thank you Jeff just a few questions
um hiya
um
the just am I created the apartment
three-story apartment blocks are on the
northernmost part which is the highest
part in the so are they going to be
prominent if they're at the highest part
they will be prominent
um so what you haven't seen on those
plans
um is is part of the outline uh we there
has to be a provision for a new Village
Center
um which will include a village hall and
shops and also some residential so
what's happened is those uh Big Flats
that you've seen the three-story
um they create a bit of a focal point to
help way find from The Village Center
into the different bits or the
development so they will be prominent
but it will have a green Space Between
The Village Center itself and uh and the
development so it's just a way of
helping people to find their way around
using those landmark buildings right
okay and with the apartment blocks they
say that they all the apartments in
there foldable or they're some market
and no they they are all affordable all
of the apartments so it's a mix of one
and two bedroom units in the apartments
okay and one other thing um the cycle
way and are there any other cycle paths
within the
on within the development and are they
dedicated or are they shared with
um
pedestrians which are going to cause
again yeah so that's something that came
up with phase one I think um that shared
sort of surface between pedestrians and
cycleways that is carrying carrying on
through the site where I showed it to be
um there's no other cycle ways actually
around the green space that's foot path
instead of cycleways on the actual road
to that there's no Circle
I don't believe so no
okay dude thanks a lot
thank you Council champion
Busby
try a different one
um
I'll shout overlay
can you go to slide 12 I think
uh sorry nine I think it was
uh yeah that's the one the
the
brown
roads the ones that aren't being adopted
who will be responsible for the
maintenance of those
I would imagine that it would be the
management company
or the residents that actually access
from those private drives
yeah if it's the the residents that's
not satisfactory really is it it's only
going to take
one resident to decide not to contribute
what do I do about it I mean the roads
will be in a good Dreadful State
especially if they're not tarmac
some kind of permeable service
I suppose
I think we need to batten down a decent
maintenance plan on those
Sam any comments on that last question I
don't have any comments name
cancer
well so
to flutter of her hand earlier on
right thank you
um just a quick one
Sam
in the report it talks about
surface water drainage being managed by
suds
and anglian Waters saying that they will
if they're going to manage the Suds then
they need to be involved in the design
Etc I thought that Suffolk County
Council were the principal Authority on
terms of Suds because when I sat on the
joint emergency planning committee here
in this very chamber when Suds was first
introduced
there was a bit of a battle as to who
would be responsible for Suds whether it
would be District councils as the
planning authorities or County Council
and County Council one in the end partly
because they thought they could get some
revenue from it but that's a that's
another story but they are the principal
Authority as far as studs are concerned
so why on Earth are angling water
involved haven't they got enough
problems polluting our waterways at the
moment uh yeah it's quite an interesting
thing that's only uh just started to
come to light actually that they are
happy and green water that is are happy
to adopt some of the suds
um I think partly is a control of what
goes through their system
um so they don't want to see flooding
is something that's being worked on at
the moment they will only take suds and
adopt them if they are to the relevant
standards that they think are
appropriate so most of the time you're
correct it is Suffolk County that would
adopt them I'm not sure what is
happening with the adoption of them in
this particular case because that's all
dealt with later on but certainly a
county are happy with what's being
provided so far
and that's a separate discharge of
condition has come in for that for phase
two and they're happy so someone is
going to adopt them whether it's anglian
mortar or whether it's a County
I'm not sure
thank you Kevin um just one one other
point on that Suds were supposed to be
uh natural drainage type systems rather
than feeding into something like the
sewage system so why on Earth angle in
water would be uh concerned about that
the problem of excess water going into
their system was one of their own making
when they decided that they wanted all
drainage water from new bills to go into
their system so they could charge people
extra water rates on it but that's
another story
um
looking at
on
one of your slides it was talking about
putting in trees to create a nice open
space and all the rest of it what sort
of trees are they going to be putting in
they're putting in standards or are they
putting in whips because so we all know
that a whip takes something like 30 or
40 years to come to anything fruition if
you're talking about Oak it's probably
100 years before it comes to anything
from remotely
reasonable so what sort of trees are
they are they going to be putting in to
create this impression that they've
shown with all their graphics and all
the rest of it
you are right they are graphics and
they're probably showing them in a few
years time of what the trees are going
to be looking like
um my understanding is that they will be
putting in uh
not whips but more mature plants
um but that has all been agreed with the
landscape obviously so she's looked at
the detail of that she's happy with that
it's just some of the other details that
she's not quite so happy with so
surfacing materials and also some of the
planting in the courtyard parking Bays
she wanted that to be a more green and
uh nicer place to be
thanks chairman uh well yes I know that
a few is normally three or four
um I think the difference between a
small a small
whip type tree I put in
um and what it would look like in three
years time is probably a considerable
difference from what they showed in
their Graphics so I think we took we
could almost take those Graphics as
being pure fiction and forget about them
all together
um the other point concern that I had
was on this business of um
tandem parking
Triple Town and parking County highways
are not very happy about it I understand
from what councilor beer was saying that
they're prepared to make an exception in
this case how wide are the roads on this
estate because I know that a lot of
modern Estates the roads are the bare
minimum width and if you end up with
excessive cars parked on there then
emergency vehicle access refuse car cart
access Etc is severely restricted also
where we have Courtyard parking for
certain of the properties
we know people don't like using them
because they don't like the fact that
their car is out of their sight at night
and can be broken into quite easily and
car crime is one of the the increasing
crimes in uh in Suffolk so uh are we
looking at the parking provision in a
more constructive and responsible way or
are we just sort of saying well this
will do we'll let it get up and get on
with it
so yeah parking is one of those planning
rubs isn't it what is the best type of
parking so visually having uh those
houses that are open fronted onto the
public spaces
um where there aren't any Vehicles it's
much more attractive
and safer probably for children that are
playing in those areas so actually the
parking Courtyards can be a really
really good idea
the difference with this one is the
electric vehicle charging points are
provided in all of those spaces so as we
move across to electric vehicles more
and more you will see that people will
be parking in their designated Bays
rather than leaving their vehicles on
roads as they currently can because they
will need to charge them before using
them
um
oh in terms of the on-road parking
there is quite a lot of visitor parking
that's been provided and they are lay by
style so they're actually off the road
um so hopefully that will encourage
people to use those parking Bays rather
than just leaving their vehicles where
they may be damaged or hit
that's all I can say really it's a
matter of common sense for the residents
really
thank you councilor McLaren
thank you Mr
some thank you as always for a very
comprehensive presentation
um I just I'm a bit concerned about the
comments that were made by Suffolk
County council at
the um the pop the public footpath
and the
um attenuation Basin at the sudden end
of that which is on page 21 and
um
port and it was I was concerned about
items three and four
um
presume this attenuation Basin is this
going to be liable to flooding as well
my understanding is that um the swales
um
will be dry unless they're you know
there is heavy rain for example how
we've had it recently where we've had a
lot of rainfall just within a few hours
normally that drains away quite quickly
um
so it's just a means of holding the
water so that it can drain around those
areas that are deeper attenuation basins
they will be fencing around them to to
help to safeguard Public Safety
I think every time we get an application
and we it always concerns me
because familiarity breeds content and
if you're passing a sort of a dip that's
normally dry and we we did a site
inspection the other week and the the
thing was fairly full now for that
really is a hazard to small children and
anybody else that might you know fall in
and I just wondered if we can enforce
what is
protection that goes around them I just
think I did see the fencing the other
week and it was inadequate I mean
anybody could have climbed through the
veins saying well what do we as a plan
in Authority can we enforce the other
thing they said was it was clear I don't
know whether he wants I think it was
slide nine or slide 47 where we could
see where that boat that the one that's
raised by Suffolk County Council where
Howard Jays sent to the fourth path that
is is it very close to
I practice the better one
this one here
we've got the footpath and then
it might be easier to see than on the
later slides actually
sorry lots of clicking
we're nearly there
so uh was it this one that you were
concerned about it's the southern end of
the footpath
that's what they I presume the footpath
is to the left isn't it yeah
yeah that's it that's a comment by
Suffolk County Council yes
is this area here so the footpath runs
along here right okay
okay so this is actually quite a shallow
Swale
um
and it's quite wide so uh it will just
be quite a naturally flowing dip this
one probably is the one that they're
more concerned about and this has
actually got knee rail around it
so you wouldn't accidentally be able to
slip in there if it happened to be
a bit slippy on the path or you know a
bit wet on the grass
so we can't enforce anything
more than that
the trouble is
and I this is another difficulty isn't
it
um in the past we have insisted on
higher fencing around those areas but if
a child wants to get in there then the
fence is actually quite a fun thing to
climb over on a bit of a challenge
um an excellent for hiding
so
it's trying to get that balance right
this the swales and the attenuation
basins are designed much more
thoughtfully these days and you don't
have those really steep sides that you
used to see around many of the
attenuation basins these are much more
um you know sort of flowing because
really they want to be used as play
areas it all forms part of the open
space areas
um certainly
at Suffolk County Council floods team
have not raised any objection to what
has been designed here so I think it's a
rights of way are just pointing out that
there might be a risk but I think the
risk is quite low and you do have that
natural surveillance from these houses
that face onto that area I know not
everyone's going to be looking out their
Windows all the time but it does help
with people coming and going and
you know hopefully is going to be a
well-used space where there'll be lots
of people enjoying that open space and
we'll be keeping an eye on people so
yeah it is a difficult one but actually
in landscape terms
knee rails are the best thing visually
for that area
that are the
was about the
um
the playground sort of causing an
obstruction to the footpath
yeah I wasn't I wasn't too sure about
that really if I just
slide where the play equipment
so
the play area is here and the footpath
runs by the side of it I think there
were concerns from County that you know
the footpath would run right through the
middle of that play area but I don't
from that plan it doesn't show me that
at all okay thanks Sam thank you chair
thank you Captain mccrroll
thank you Mr chairman
um Hi Sam I'm just looking at the pages
24 and 25 of the comments from public
realm on the 1st of the 6th and the 10th
of the sixth and I wondered if the plans
since the application has been worked on
over these months since whether the
applicant has taken on board the
comments about biodiversity the uh the
range of trees being planted there is a
tendency to use the national generic
although it could be described I think
very often as the Taylor wimpy generic
no offense intended uh but you know you
do tend to see the same planting schemes
along a number of Estates so have those
comments from net public realm been
taken on board and included in the
planting of different species and
something that's perhaps a bit more
natural to the Suffolk and the baber
environment
yeah so this is a quite an interesting
thing and this is quite new as well so
uh public realm didn't used to really
talk about the detail of planting and
this is certainly the first application
where I've had where they have
um and I know it's something that
they're moving more into we're much more
conscious about uh biodiversity because
of Net game that's required now
um so all of our consultations have
previously been with Essex Police
Services their landscape team they've
been involved all the way through the
pre-apps through all the consultations
so they're the comments so we've really
sort of focused on
and they are quite fussy and because we
also use uh Essex Place for Ecology they
talk to each other and they work
together so
um
I would say I would probably be taking
their comments above what is written
here
um
but certainly in the future maybe is
something to think about if we're going
to be getting quite detailed comments
like this then uh you know we should be
looking at those as well but I don't
think there are any
conflicts between the Essex and the
baber public realm I think it's just
that there's mention of um I think
concern about Beach for example which uh
may be more subject to climate change
scenarios the reason I raised this and I
think it's important is about the
management of the public open space the
planting as has been really mentioned
for the next 10 years what Arrangements
I mean there's this whole Chilton Woods
development is going to involve a great
number of these strips of open space and
planting schemes and it strikes me that
the quantity in total is probably far
too large for a single or even two or
three Parish councils to be able to
handle you know it's not the parish
councils have teams of landscapers
gardeners they can cut grass it's about
it really
public realm aren't going to be taking
on any of this space and I assume that
applies across the children Woods sites
what Arrangements have the developers
proposed for the long-term maintenance
of all the public open space not just in
phase two but phase one and all the
phases still to come because it strikes
me as though
we could well be left on the parishes
could well be left with is holding the
baby as it were in 10 years time when
the initial Arrangements have been
completed there needs to be some
long-term thinking about this
uh yeah and perhaps that's something
that Taylor wimpy can answer today but
certainly
um management plans are required
um so and that's all to do with the
outline so
um we would have to look to see what's
actually been arranged through those
dischargeable conditions
just to help my colleague um presumably
when these are built out the councils
both Parish
districts and County will receive quite
a large amount of council tax which is
part of what is provided in that council
tax to provide the public realm that
function that they would normally carry
out so there is a responsibility you
know we do obviously receive quite a lot
of income from these new properties and
so that income probably would be divided
to help
that public realm it just really needs
that it is sorted out at a stage of
who's responsible
um because there is income coming in
it's not as if there's no income
uh I think that probably is fair
um but as I say I don't know the details
of how that public open space is going
to be handed over in the future so
I only mention it because specifically
the report states that the Open Spaces
will not be transferred to the district
council so I wouldn't want to see the
parishes having to hold all the
responsibility of that was all
congressman
thank you Mr chair
um on page 25 Sam we've got a comment by
the way services
are we going to as that's being raised
by them as a concern that identifiable
bin placed sites are we going to
apply some requirement around that
it's terrible if your bin was not
collected and that because somebody
couldn't see it
um I believe that Suffolk County Council
highways were happy with the bin uh
presentation areas so I don't think
that's a problem
well but they're asking that there's
certain points could be more prominent
Brazil still the the waste collection
vehicle can identify
it says communal collection point for
dwellings 288 289 and 298 are hidden
um
I don't really know what to say
[Laughter]
um
I think
I think people will want their bins to
be emptied and they will make sure that
they present them in a way that is
acceptable
um and that people can find them I
suppose it's
seeing something on paper and actually
driving around and seeing the bins is
slightly different so it is a cons a
concern for Waste Services but it wasn't
so for Suffolk County Council so
I do I just think I mean it's it
happened actually in my ward
and um it's very annoying for the
residents which have to keep ringing up
and saying my
bin has not been collected I mean it's
it's three properties I know that's not
a lot but it could cause people a lot of
inconvenience
thank you come after you have a look at
that Sam and and
thank you thank you
Council
[Music]
school end
and will it come forward because because
Sylvia makes a very good point about
parking
it seems that we're making decisions
today based on having a lack of evidence
and information in front of us about the
school which could have a huge
consequence on that spine road that goes
through into this state so I think it's
quite relevant that we know
not necessarily the owner but when that
application has come forward if it's
going to come forward how far I've
counted got with it because we're making
these decisions based on phases that
eventually all blend together and
Interlink and yet we're going blind
about what's to its left what's to its
top what's to its right and we're making
decisions and all we'll end up with is
is
blocks of phases that not don't
necessarily blend with the others so I
think the school is quite an important
one here in that how it affects that
spine Road how the traffic's going to
get to it and my colleague to my left
has actually made a very good point to
myself that majority of people may well
walk and cycle but I think there's a
very important thing that we we should
have an understanding of when we make
decisions like this on these sort of
phases okay so firstly um today's
application you're literally just
looking at phase two so just
contained within that red site nothing
outside to put your mind at rest Suffolk
County council do own the Primary School
site it will be coming forward because
it's actually one of the conditions
within the section 106 agreement I don't
have that document with me at the moment
but I think it's when once you get to a
certain threshold in the number of
dwellings that that has to be delivered
so it will be coming forward but we
haven't reached that threshold point at
the moment we you have no idea how it's
going to blend in with that phase the
access point or anything do you
could it be a factor laying the access
point couldn't help the spine Road the
access no the uh action Lane is going to
be pedestrianized so we're Reynolds Way
goes up to it and you've got that
crossroads at the moment uh that that
will be bollarded off so that then forms
a cycle link through
I'll add it off
so traffic will be taken around the main
distributor Road around Chilton Woods I
believe
I might have that wrong but that was my
understanding okay um and then uh cycles
and pedestrians will be using that piece
of um Acton Lane
um as a green area and a sustainable
travel link
later
in the meantime
we have
the applicant
Samuel castlin
you have three minutes to address the
committee and then if you'll stay
seeking afterwards because I think you
might be getting some more questions
thank you chair and good morning
councilors my name's Sam kazlin I'm the
planning manager at Taylor wimpy I've
been working on the site uh since the
start of 2020 when we acquired the site
as during the site acquisition stage
actually we inherited it off our East
Anglia region which I'm sure you're
familiar with I have no intention of
taking up too much of your time this
morning because the officer report and
presentation excellently surmised the
application
we have been doing our best to be good
neighbors on sites at Chilton Woods it
has been a challenging summer it's very
dry so that we did have issues with dust
um and we've had the environmental
health Officer Down on site and they
were happy that we were doing everything
we can to could to control that and we
also did get despite our best efforts
and very explicit instructions the odd
idiot driver coming in from wherever
they choose my the site manager on site
Chris has assured me that it you know 99
of the time it's right and it's just
it's just the odd instance
the good news is that we are making good
progress on site and we're on course to
welcome our first occupants we've got 20
people scheduled to move in in December
so next month
the application before you has been
developed in close consultation with
Council officers Suffolk County Council
highways the drainage landscape and
ecology offices
the application includes 30 affordable
homes and the associated housing
landscaping and play Space
the proposals have been shared and
discussed with the working group during
their development and have been
developed alongside the design code
they've been assessed in detail within
the design and access statement again
against the design code criteria so
there's ticks where they where it
Accords with all those points and the
materials selected for the homes to
record with the design code particularly
the boundary treatments which cause for
darker bricks to be used on on the
outward facing parcel boundaries
these homes will not have gas boilers
It's Our intention to supply the heat
and hot water to them through a
centralized Community heat Hub so a
large air source heat pump effectively
that application was submitted near
enough alongside this application that
you're considering today so hopefully
that'll get to a planning committee in
the very near future for you
uh the application does present the next
crucial step in the delivery of the
strategically important site and
unlocking the delivery of new homes at
Chilton Woods
um like every other business we are
operating in a really challenging
environment uh but we are absolutely
committed to delivering this site and
and doing a good job of it we therefore
hope that you agree with your officer's
recommendation and vote to approve this
application this morning
if I've got spare time I can pick up
some of the questions now
try to make a little bit of notes it's
always the Blasted parking isn't it but
um if I start with the the school we we
have been working and working with the
education Authority on uh the designs
for the school we have seen early
designs and I think it's always a
balance for schools isn't it with
some School drop-off and parking they
don't want to provide too much because
it encourages people to drive and drop
and drive people to school when there's
a you know other sustainable methods
like scooting or cycling or even walking
uh the the early designs we've seen
included drop-off facilities and a a
coach parking as well within the School
boundary I think they don't they like
having it within the within the actual
um
cartilage of the school site so that
that's the designs we've seen and the
access is off the spine Road
um
so so they're aware of that
management companies that they're always
fairly divisive as well for everyone and
there's been a bit of discussion about
um parking or open space Etc where
open space roads are private and they're
not going to be adopted they they will
be controlled by a management company we
do have an adoption plan for that we we
will build it and complete it up to spec
and then it's handed over to the
management company when when they're
happy with that and they take
responsibility for the maintenance and
repair Etc uh the
residents when they move into the homes
are aware that they have to make a
contribution to the management company
it's just like paying your mortgage or
your council tax or your Netflix
subscription you know you've got to
um you you do have to um they will be
budgeting accordingly for that and uh
there there are rules I think in terms
of what uh the management company
ongoing cost how much it can increase by
per year as per costs includes so there
will be a kitty to
um maintain those spaces
I think there might be a supplementary
to that particular question councilor
beer you wanted to uh thank you yeah
just um I've only got two points and
touched on both of them but the the road
around the school have you any
um plans or any procedure that you would
put into place
um to stock Park and along there because
um you may not be aware but for the
local Parish Council which I think it
most likely would be Chilton that would
Commander it can take up to two years to
get yellow lines put in to stock Park
and and I accept that you're saying that
they can park inside and there'll be
drop-off points and all that we have
them now at lots of schools they don't
work people will still turn up the fact
we're trying to get them to cycle
scooter and all the other things we're
not giving up our cars so I do feel you
have a responsibility that even though
it may not be
particularly this application that it
needs to be sorted but you need to be
aware that you will be creating a
problem my second question unless you
want to answer that one first
but now far away I think I'll try to
remember two points
um the second one why is it that you've
chosen and not to have all your roads
adopted because my colleague in front of
me who brought up the point earlier
about
um
the adopted roads
any any roads that are unadopted this
adds more pressure on to the people
purchasing your homes now I know we
insist on charging points and panels and
other fins and that puts the cost of
dwellings up because we as counselors
are very aware that fins that we ask for
are provided and it's passed on to the
person buying the house but here
surely
to have a road that they've got to
maintain that is no cheap item and
further down the road this does become a
problem as my colleagues have been left
of me said that if one of them didn't
want to agree and the little cul-de-sac
it causes big problems is this because
you want to find a cheap way to provide
more homes on the site so your
compromising on making the roads not up
to County standard thank you
foreign
thank you I'll start with the first
point and the point on the school and
and what we can do we
think it's not actually the application
we're considering with the spine
waveforms part of the main
infrastructure works that's already been
adopted but it's regardless it's still a
really important Point
um and I you know you do experience you
know you see someone who's obviously
needs are more important than anyone
else's and they Park wherever they're
wherever they like
um we the main spine Road will be an
adoptable road so it won't be for us to
provide any enforcement but I think
it'll be a point as and when the
education Authority will bring forward
their plans that they might um obviously
be working with the highways authorities
think okay what sort of restrictions and
um
if there is any sort of enforcement that
we need to put in place to prevent
people blocking or parking on the spine
road so that that will be an issue I'm
sure that will be discussed as and when
that's brought forward and um most
definitely when you uh can consider the
application for the for the school when
that comes forward
um
on
roads and adopting roads uh it probably
won't we'd actually love every road that
we built to be adopted for the reasons
that you outline it does provide a cost
to us and it's a constant leap have to
pass on to the residents through the
management company it's it a real
balance I think
there's a talk with a highways Authority
about their reticence because obviously
if they Adopt A Highway it's more for
them to approve Etc so they do have
quite stringent rules and in terms of
what they will and won't adopt and for a
lot of these sort of secondary streets
they they don't really want to actually
adopt them so it's
it's not a case of us trying to build
things cheaply or or do you know Dodge a
fee we'd love to get these adopted but
it's more a case that you can't
spec of the roads and the spec of the
smaller
let's say not secondary
Road secretary
are to just to an extent that the
highways won't adopt them
so just come back very quickly on that
last point but up until very recently
any states that build housing Estates
basically had their roads adopted This
Is A New Concept I know we've done it in
Long Melford but this is reasonably new
and I've heard from people who live in
longmelford on the new estate they're
horrified to find that they've got to
find money for this road are you telling
me in all honesty that when if I came
along to buy one of those houses there
you're in one of these smaller streets
you're going to say to me you must
remember you will be responsible for
paying for the road and most likely the
life it's it's not as I don't think you
will yeah it's um it all gets picked up
I mean we're talking about a scheme here
that's got 1150 homes so the the bulk of
those that will be on adoptable Highway
and be accessed from that so it's it's a
shared communal cost that that will be
going through it so it won't just be the
five residents in front of the private
drive that have to pay for it it'll come
out of the large communal pots for that
contrary
okay
um
I was just picking up on what public
realm said about the equipment the play
equipment about wooden equipment I
easily caught fire and things like that
is there any way of changing that so
it's not wooden
I
I mean the the it's detailed within the
application so it might be that a
further condition that we explore for
other things we have used uh wooden play
Space on on other developments and we
use it here I
there's a real balance I think in terms
of where where we're using it on this
site it's it's on a footpath it's
alongside quite what's intended to be a
sort of a fairly
close to Nature walkway and I think it's
probably more appropriate to have those
wooden features there than it would be
for example where the lap where you
might have larger features that it might
be in a bit more of a destination play
area
um
it's it's a balance I think once you
start putting in sort of the metal play
equipment with bright red or blue
aluminous painting on it it starts to
look probably a bit more unsightly and
maybe not appropriate for that location
and um defibs is there any chance of
putting something
defibrillators in in on this one
um I don't see why not I don't I
I probably bit out my comfort zone in
terms of what the costs are and getting
power Etc to them if they're battery
charged or something I know they're
quite often in places where there's
maybe a slightly higher foot full
I'm just assumed that we'd have those in
the neighborhood center so just to the
north of the site
um and I think it would be something we
can consider
if not part of this application but
maybe something where we go back and
install those so
yeah
thanks chair
um just a couple of things
um any of the houses got PV panels and
if so how many
off the top of my head I don't know
there are there is an energy report
that's been submitted with this
application so that that does outline
that's why the need for um the
percentage of the PV I don't know what
that is off the top of my head though so
there is some it's not all
you're expecting to some at least yes
and the other thing given you've got a
blank canvas
why on your cycleways are you shared
sharing them with pedestrians why not
separate them to block avoid potential
conflict in the future
I think um
in terms of how you do that obviously
the the footpath and cycleways are
of a sufficient width inspect to mean
that they can be shared
um
I think you might have diff I suppose
you could twin track them in terms of
how how they you know put them side by
side I I don't I don't know what the the
benefits are of doing that with of
separating them whether it's in
um obviously if you do that might take
up a bit more of your open space
I don't know is is it is it an issue
where you've got sufficient space on the
on a shared footpath cycle way that you
have conflict
my experience is that is the
when you've got enough width that's fine
the footpaths and the pedestrians can
use them
okay
come through here
[Music]
thank you Mr chairman um just a quick
one I was looking through a report and
couldn't see anything about Johnny uh
where we're talking about unadopted
roads and adopted roads in the past
Council have insisted on Street lighting
where there are adopted roads there's
been no mention anywhere than the report
of Street lighting or whether that would
be provided uh I know the mppf does say
that where there isn't any Street
lighting at the moment it doesn't you
can say you can that you can't enforce
Street lighting but it can be uh an
optional
are you proposing any street life
anymore yeah I I think typically we have
Street lighting to be agreed by
condition so um the details and and what
sort of how the lighting columns Etc
look
um a done post planning so uh yes there
will be Street lighting and bollards Etc
so people will be able to navigate their
way through in the dark winter months
okay
thank you chair Hi Sam
um
I'm going to come back to the management
plan because I'd just like to know when
that's covering both Landscaping
planting maintenance and the unadopted
roads is that correct that's correct yes
indeed just reminded me as well about
the tree planting and um
we we've organized and we've had quite a
bit discussion with members of the
working group as well about appropriate
use and and using local local trees and
local planting as well so it's not just
whatever you know whatever we can import
from Germany on the cheap it's there's
there's a lot of consideration and our
Landscape Architects have been working
really well hardly on well and that's to
ensure there's appropriate planting
obviously it's there's a balance to be
struck as well so it's it's about we're
going to be doing a lot of planting on
this site so it's about what we can
secure and what we can get in the
quantities that we need for this cycle
because at the moment I know planting
schemes are constantly changing because
we expect we know that the climate is
going to get warmer and even a couple of
degrees can change the uh the future of
the particular species what I'm asking
though is um how long is the management
plan that is required I think in the
outline permission is that right yes how
long is that secured for
and and how can it be secured for not
only the first buyers but future buyers
um can that be done by condition yeah
are we are we going to run out of a
management company in 10 years time I I
I I think the land gets transferred to
them so and then they contractually
obliged I don't know what it is whether
it's some sort of lease or whatever and
it's 999 years or whatever that they
have to be responsible for looking after
and maintaining that so the management
companies can change
um and I think they have to come back to
us and approve that that change but um
yes they are they are tied in
contractually to that
can I ask planning officers if that's
been secured or can be secured by
condition or is it already been dealt
with and in the past
are you talking about the management
company that will be looking after the
site after Taylor Wimpy have left or or
something I'm thinking about the
long-term management future of that and
whether that is securable by condition
um
I I think that is something that is
between the developer and whoever the uh
the new management company is going to
be
um and maybe Christine can confirm this
if that is a legal document or not I'm
not too sure
I was just um looking through our system
to see when the section 106 was done
because we'd normally put it in section
106 in the transfer arrangements and the
details of the transfer document would
be put in that so all the covenants
um I can't find it at the moment but if
you'll give me a bit of time I can have
a look and maybe come back to you on
that but in essence it is Asia securable
with the applicant for them to carry the
responsibility of setting up the future
of the management plan is that correct
yes that's correct but they have to do
that with whoever that is but then that
their responsibility is the initial one
that's fine thank you
it was Council Osborne next sorry
thank you Mr chairman um I had three
questions but uh councilor Hinton is
very uh gone into the lighting situation
which I I just needed to clarify the
fact that you have roads there that um
I haven't been adopted therefore would
the lightning still be attended to on
those areas and I think that was
answered by by yourself
just
something that's happened during the
area of uh of heat and dust Etc on your
site
we've
as cancer as we've had
in our Wards anyway particular
residents complaining about the problems
with dust and it still went on after the
finish of that these were on on roadways
which backed on to the back of your
development are you
Reynolds way and Aubry drive and in
particular the position we've
the
health of particular residents that have
had problems can I just ask you
can I get you to clarify will you are
you able to actually enforce a stronger
positions on this because
we you don't seem to have actually dealt
with those uh from from the complaints
that we have recently
I I was I've been made aware of the Dust
issue I think you've raised it in the
past as well and and I've I've chatted
with Chris on site and you met Chris he
is his phone he you can always contact
Chris and he'll talk you through if
there's any problems he's more than
happy to help but
the the dust as you were
exacerbated by a particularly dry summer
it's probably didn't help that the
particular phase of the infrastructure
Works exception that we are doing is
right next to those residents as well
this summer
but as I mentioned that the
environmental health officer did come
and visit the site and check that we
were doing everything that we were
required to do Under the um
the construction sites management plan
as well and was content that we were
doing it it's it's it's just been a
really unfortunate situation I'm
surprised particularly coming into
Ipswich this morning that thus there's
still an issue and how much how wet it's
been recently but if it's still an
ongoing issue it's something that
best raised with the site manager Chris
on site I can provide his contact
details and and we can talk talk to him
about that and he can he can talk you
through the measures he's taking I'm not
I'm not sure I mean I think we've got
quite stringent dust suppression
measures on site as it is and wheel
washing and spraying down Etc
um I'm not sure I think if the eho
wanted to see more things on site they'd
have asked for it in the summer
uh well I do appreciate that
you know construction can be a noisy in
a dirty neighbor and um
no I appreciate it there's things
there's any site we can we can mitigate
but I think when in certain scenarios
it's going to be I appreciate you've had
the environmental the health people
there looking at these things and coming
back however even after that there were
still complaints from uh areas around
where you were
and I would like to see that any of the
residents with health problems and they
were quite heavy health problems that
they had would actually be dealt with by
yourselves iron you know on fully uh
aware of of your efforts to provide
things within that construction area but
you know it's not a wise move to have
people uh complaining about the dust and
and the problems that they have
health-wise and having to visit
hospitals
um I just if I may if if you do have
suggestions or things that you think we
could be doing then um feel free to
raise them and um we will consider that
consider their implementation but
um
yeah yeah Sam I understand what what
you're saying but you know from my point
of view if you were saying that you are
really concentrating on getting these
sorted out I'm happy but those people
that are got complaints could we could
we sort of deal with it in a in a more
timely uh
position the other Factor Mr chairman I
just wanted to ask um
on some of the uh outline plans that we
saw you had buffer zones around the
around the areas that you were dealing
with you know Green buffer zones
can you just clarify what you've
actually got there now
huh
so I'm not sure page Rose and stuff that
you were going to you know you're going
to have a 10 meter barrier or whatever
yeah in terms of some of the advanced
planting that we've done yeah yeah I I
can't comment because I um
I actually haven't been down on the site
but I know they've got a lot of the
planting in so I've been down there
recently but I can provide an update
maybe through sand and and get that
dispersed through members so you can see
what they're done I mean alternatively
we're always welcome to a site visit if
members feel like they'd like to come
and see the progression and what we're
doing on site and
um and then I suppose they you can see
some of the measures we put into site
safety and managing dirt mess and noise
Etc as well so that's something that
we'd also be happy to facilitate well
perhaps that's a good way out of it and
as I say I've had the fortunate position
of actually having the site visit early
on when you was in just doing the
archeology stuff on that yeah off just
offer active line so yeah I appreciate
it and thank you Sam but let's say those
issues are
so what do we thank you Mr chairman
thank you
Professor McLaren
German
y
um
back to the bins
sorry that back to the waistband yes yes
yes
in the report what was the by the way so
have you to know to that I I I think
um obviously we we do look at this and
we look at this on all of our
developments in terms of
so you go through all these measures at
the start of the site to make sure that
everything looks nice in your street
scenes are great and you know that when
people move in they dump their wheelie
bends out the front and it all goes to
the pot anyway so I I can't comment on
those specific measures I know that we
did go back and review a lot of them and
I I think it's just the point that
it's a case-by-case basis isn't it
people people if you don't if you miss
your bin day you you know about it don't
you because you've got to live with all
that waste on you on your doors for a
week so I think people will make the
effort to drag their bins out and make
them prominent and drag them back so I I
don't know about those particular drag
distances I'd have to go and check and
check those on the plans but
um
I think it's I think what I would say
it's um
it's not often we do get a comment by
the way services so I thought but in
fact if you look at the end of the
report
there is reviewing that anyway okay
um but as it's a public meeting I didn't
want to raise it again yeah as a
resident if I'd paid a lot of money for
a house I'd like to
I'd like to be an empty I was paying
council tax I would like to think my
bins have been empty and I I wonder if
it's up to members if they want to do
that if they if they that could be
something that they could seek to add in
terms of a condition just to be sure
that the um
the Waste Management strategy is is
correctly signed off and endorsed well
at the end of the report it actually
used to sell but I did want to raise it
publicly thank you Sam thank you chair
okay Council McLaren I'll go back to Sam
to reference that one
sorry I know it's annoying I keep
slides
uh three plots uh that way Services have
identified as being a bit of a problem
are actually
just here
right on the main distributor Road
so right in front of the three houses in
question there's a little bit of a Verge
with a tree
so
I don't think visually is going to be a
problem for the bin men to actually pick
up that they're supposed to be picking
bins up from that area because they're
right on the main distributor Road
but
thank you Sam
are there any more questions for the
applicant
oh no the lights come on I can see you
are
counselor Busby would you like to ask
your question
yeah 242 dwellings no Bungalows see
appointing is there any reason why that
is the case
not not specifically I think in terms of
sort of m42 m43 access we we incorporate
those those units and those smaller
units
um within the apartment blocks
I I think I'm I've this has been raised
I think on our on our original
application that we we find there's a
bit of a um
trying to find the right word
we we get differing opinions on
Bungalows when people ask for them and
when we've delivered them and we've done
it not on this site but we've done it on
other sites and everyone says oh there's
a massive demand for bungalows people
want Bungalows we build the Bungalows
and we always struggle to sell them and
when we do sell them it's a heavily
discounted rate so it does
the evidence that we've experienced is
that there's not a great call for
bungalows
um
and and we do generally struggle to sell
them
um I'm not saying that we we couldn't
put any on the in the future of the site
and it's yeah if there is a need for
bungalows and it is a proven need then
I'm sure we'd be we'd be happy to
deliver some Bungalows on the site but
it's it we do find that better delivered
through the apartment blocks
um
and and that's how we've done it
so there is a range and a mix of houses
it's just there's no Bungalows on
well because personally I think for
every two and a half and three story
dwelling that you put up you should also
put up a bungalow to counterbalance it
we all were ended up doing is raising
the height of all of our Estates
I hear what you say about
those but there are people that want my
clothes maybe you're not putting them in
the right places or or
we are charging too much for them
um
you can't have it both ways
thank you okay does it appeared you wish
to come back on Bungalows just on that
point and I'm glad my colleague has
picked that up because I hadn't realized
um but we we had started getting
developers to put in a few Bungalows
because despite what you've just said uh
Bungalows are the most sought under
properties in great cornard for a start
and I gather their sought after in most
other towns and Villages so to suggest
that uh it's difficult to sell I'm
really surprised to hear that comment
where they've been put on the Estates I
gather most of the Bungalows have sold
first
there's some on a private part of the
Chilton wood it's nothing to do the
children would but on off the um Chilton
Road waldenfield Road there they've got
Bungalows and all of them went very very
quickly
um in Newton green we had some Bungalows
and I think they had about five or six
people for every Bungalow that they sold
there was only about six or eight along
there it's about six I think
um so
I'm pleased to hear you say that you
would consider them on future sites that
you bring forward because I would
respectfully ask members to try and
remember next time that we do want
Bungalows because they should have been
some supplied here and I'm disappointed
there isn't any
um so anyway next time I'll pay a bit
more alert I hope my colleagues will be
as well thank you
I hear that question thanks a bit
um
any more questions
all right thank you very much
something okay we will move on we have
no objectives nobody from the Town
Council but we do have a statement from
Jan Oswald
Mr chairman and members my apologies for
not being able to attend the meeting in
person I'm pleased to see that the site
will provide 30 of affordable housing
Although our policy is for 35 for 30
exceeds requirements of the section 106
agreement I support this application but
I do have some areas of concern which I
hope the committee will look at before
making their decision
I would have liked to have seen more
Bungalows as there currently is a need
for those people wishing to live
independently and those with a
disability
where open green spaces are provided
could the committee please request that
these are protected from Cars bands Etc
using them for parking
share great morning field Parish Council
and Acton Parish council's comment
regarding the use of red bricks which is
in conflict with the design code part
page 19 of the report
please also note SCC public right-of-way
and access comments on page 21 and SCC
highways comments on page 23.
regards councilor Jan Osborne thank you
chair
thank you Claire
we'll remember any questions but um so
let's move on
um would somebody like to open the
debate
Chancellor Barrett yes I'd like a date
debate uh this is another
good opportunity to get Woods delivered
um I I see that this is probably one of
the most debated uh applications we've
had for a number of years everyone's
very familiar with it I'm not quite sure
what was left to debate or argue about
um bearing in mind that the design code
has been adhered to which we approved
previously so I would like to propose
that we I go with the officer
recommendation for the uh plan uh in
front of us could I have a second to
please
yeah thank you um thank you Mr chairman
I'd just like to uh say Taylor Wimpy
have been excellent in their
consultations
did the council a second or not I didn't
hear him say anything other than trying
to congratulate people
I think if you've just wait and you'll
you'll hear that it comes to Osborne did
offer to second he is allowed to speak
as you should know so thank you very
much but Council Osborne would you like
to finish thank you very much Mr
chairman yeah I would just um just
stating that the consultations that
they've carried out with all councils
and and the virtual meetings that
they've carried out probably twice a
month or even
well depending upon how how you were
situated so I congratulate them on that
and I have no um no problem in in second
in this this proposal thank you
thank you councilor Osborne
we have a motion on the table with
anybody does anybody want to further
some further debate councilor Hinton I
think you wish
yes um I'm not going to propose all
second it's already been done and the
fundamentally uh
all the potential
difficulties have been highlighted and
questioned from the officers and the and
the applicant
um one point that I would just like to
mention that has been quite a lot of
discussion about bungalows
and their Source they aren't very
popular with developers I know because
they take up so much land compared to
their accommodation space if you're
talking about 100 square meters of
accommodation space for a three bedroom
five occupancy property
then it's 100 square meters of land
whereas if it was a house because it
goes up it takes up less space but
there is a requirement for homes that
are livable in for longer periods of
time than just two or three years and
then moving on and a lot of people are a
lot of smaller builders in particular
are finding that they can sell houses
very very quickly if they use homes for
life rather than just building a
standard two up two down type sort of or
three up two down property and homes for
life are good because they can be bought
by young families and the young family
or the parents of that young family can
effectively stay there forever if they
want to because when they can't manage
the stairs there is accommodation for
them downstairs so they are the obvious
sort of crossover if you like between
Bungalows and houses
now we just endorse that concept to the
to the developer if he's if he's
listening
thank you councilor Hanson councilman
mccrroll
yeah I think uh quite a few people would
have been prepared to Second The
Proposal
um seem to be acute one moment on the
subject of Bungalows a note that 4.6 on
page 27 suggests that no units are
proposed as Bungalows the applicant is
in 10 indicated that they intend for
bungalows to come forward in future the
lower density phases in that can I just
suggest that officers and and any future
planning committee that considers those
lower phases reminds them of that when
the actual applications are being
developed if they're if there is an
intention for bungalows in the lower
density phases please let's see them
okay otherwise I'm inclined to support
the motion
thank you Council James
thank you um
regards to the motion epic to support
the most about
um
properties inside the apartments
but if they were houses we wouldn't let
so many apartments be so close together
of so many houses so close together um
fear of stigmatization
and I just wonder if
having all the flats as social housing
and the affordable houses if that also
puts a risk of stigmatizing the people
that live there and perhaps we could
look at that in the future relevance
um
that's all I want to say
how would we take that on board I'm
looking for advice
from the Strategic housing team
um and you're quite right normally we
like to see affordable units in groups
of six to eight
um in one location and that's mainly
because the housing associations uh like
them to be grouped that way and they
won't take them on unless they are
grouped that way
um I'm not too sure whether these flats
are actually being
um taken up by Baba District Council
um
so yeah it might be a bit of a tricky
one perhaps they need that type of
housing in Sudbury but
I'm not really privy to that sort of
information at the moment
certainly strategic housing didn't raise
any issues about groups of the 12
Apartments being in one block like that
um I think in future phases we probably
will be advising that we'd like to see
less one bedroom units
and see more of a mixture because
clearly there's families that need to be
housed as well
but I will leave that to my colleagues
in strategic housing to advise on that
point
thank you Sam
any more comments
no therefore chair can I just check that
we mopped up on suggested conditions um
there's no more suggestions for anything
um we'll move to a vote and prior to
that vote I'll just check with the area
planning manager what is
things there are some things that were
said earlier in the debate that I've got
buried by the passage of time so I just
want to go back on them um
we'd suggest additional condition for
materials to start with which I think
that we haven't put on the
report
just just materials yeah we'll sort that
out later the wording of that this is
standard materials condition the second
one was we had a bit of a debate about
maintenance Clauses in the 106 Etc I
don't know if Christie's had a chance to
uncover those if she hasn't then I've
got suggestion how we get around that
um I haven't been able to find the 106
so I've checked and there are um either
commuted sums and management company
Provisions within the 106. and there's a
community Woodland I think where the
management is only for 10 years
initially for the management company but
the play spaces and other areas of the
lifetime of those areas
and the initial Arrangement is for the
owner to come up with a management
company and to the council to approve it
so to have sight of it which I think is
the the real issue
so that I would suggestions is covered
off
as an issue we don't have to introduce a
new condition with members agree with
that
and the third point was defibrillators
were mentioned do you want a
defibrillator condition
s
one next to the school or
uh and the community center I thought
it's going to be close to the school
isn't it there needs to be one there
once once things developed and
alternative action where people are
congregating and where there's a
requirement for it and there's a in
Sudbury as you're probably aware there's
a very good scheme going on to put
defibrators in and they seem to be able
to find them and put them in where
they're relevant rather than us for
putting I mean as a planning condition I
think it's a bit over the top
share the only natural condition
s
okay
thank you
you're all happy with that there's the
proposal of the second
thank you
can we put a condition in for future
applications bearing in mind that they
kind of promised us Bungalows and lower
density in but not now phase
I think house must be you can instruct
you can instruct your officers to have
such conversations about subsequent
applications
on the page 47 you just mentioned about
the refuse bins
on page 47 of the of the papers it said
that the chief planning officer
delegated to approve these Reserve
matters and other conditions and one of
the conditions is about the refuse bins
if you look at page 47
I know it's three properties but it's
important one moment before you wasted
time I think Sam can fill us in what
yeah so just to clarify it was actually
Suffolk County Council highways that
asked for the condition for the refuse
bins just to make sure that the points
where people are presenting them are as
the plans the approved documents so
including those three that the waste
were worried about so thank you
okay okay
we're going to move to the vote we're
going to ask player to
which is on to
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress councilor beer can I take a
vote please for the application thank
you Council
or Busby would you like me to take your
vote verbally
oh thank you
thank you members chair that's 11 votes
for that's unanimous that's past
unanimously thank you very much
thank you the officers and the area
manager
um I
suggest we have a 10 minute break
Comfort break and we'll get back here
just after half past 11.
to deal with the next application
time we'll make a start on the next one
thank you all
it's
dc2105110 land to the south of Thompson
and Morgan Poplar Lane sprouton
um I'll ask the case up at Broad and
sprouting
somebody will correct me
yeah
and I'm one of the fewers born and bred
Suffolk um
fine
I remember the case up to Elizabeth
flood to introduce the application to
members
thank you
hybrid application at the outline
element is for a site uh to be known as
interchange 55 which would comprise
industrial warehousing office research
and Light Industry and then there's full
application for the access
Okay so
this way so this is the site you'll
remember you went on a site visit a
couple of months ago this is the A14
along here uh Thompson and Morgan here
Poplar Lane here you can just see Wolsey
Grange one being developed out here
um
Tesco is down here park and ride uh
internet interchange retail units here
and that is the scavenger Drive a12 A14
roundabout and that's the a1214 going
along here
again this is the site location plan so
what's shown in blue is is the outline
element and what's shown in red is the
fall so you can just see the full access
that will be via the park and ride site
so you can see it's upcoming here
uh you'll notice these are the houses on
London Road you'll see some photographs
of those there's sort of approximately
seven dwellings in that location uh and
there's Thompson and Morgan at the top
again constraints there aren't really
any constraints the only one is the
grade two listed building here on Poplar
Lane but you need to be aware that there
will be housing here as part of Woolsey
Grange and then Employment so actually
um this building has already or will
already have its setting Changed by
approved development uh you can also see
the the built up area boundary
technically this is outside the built up
area boundary but it is allocated for
development within the core strategy
okay existing layout you can see that
the land slopes north to south and also
the other thing to be aware of on this
are the electricity pylons which are
sort of concentrate for where
development can go again you can see the
access here into the park and via the
park and ride site and the A14 along
here
again this is the access plan sorry it's
not brilliantly clear but
what
you should be able to see it's a bit
like faint but this is where the
existing
um roundabout is so at the moment
there's a there's a there's the main
roundabout here that leads to sort of
Tesco
um and then there's a mini roundabout
here that leads to the park and ride and
then to the retail units here uh curries
and so on now what's proposed is that
this will become a priority Junction so
the main route will go along up here and
then there will be a sort of Junction
off to the retail units and a further
Junction off just one way for the park
and ride and then the park and ride will
do as it does now go around and there
will be another Junction here
to come away to come back so this would
be one way for the this will be two ways
but there will be a one-way system
within the park and ride as normal
and the parking spaces you can see that
are pale pink they're the ones to be
removed and you can probably just see up
here some new parking here so some of
them will be replaced and some of them
will be lost
the other thing to see on this plan is
there's proposed a pedestrian and cycle
access to the site so at the moment this
is the existing pedestrian and cycle
path along
London Road
and there is a proposal for it to cross
over come along here because it's a
slope it has to go quite long so that
it's it's not too Steep and then join
here and then it can get into the
um into the site
again
this shows potential well works for the
a12 14 roundabout now these have been
approved
um for the Woolsey Grange application so
these need to be undertaken for the by
the 300th
um dwelling on Woolsey Grange one but if
they haven't happened
um by the time 20 25 of this development
um and has been occupied it's proposed
that these Works will be done as part of
this application
um so you can see this is minor changes
signals here and then some alterations
to
um
to the lanes so
um the lanes just to increase some
capacity so this may well happen prior
to this application being developed
being brought forward or being developed
but if if Woolsey grain slows down for
any reason and it hasn't it would become
part of this application
this is the proposed layout so this is
just an indicative layout
so you can see the likelihood is it will
be sort of large warehouses this is
what's shown on here
um there would be a
height limit of 12 and a half meters
you can see the electricity pylons which
are likely to be retained and therefore
there won't be any development under
them
um and you can see here this is the
landscape buffer 15 meter landscape
buffer for these dwellings here to try
to protect their immunity
and you can see the access into the site
here so that's via the park and ride as
you've just seen comes through here and
into the site the other thing to be
aware of is that potentially it shows a
potential link into the Thompson and
Morgan site
um so that hgvs wouldn't would be able
to access Thompson and Morgan without
having to go along Poplar Lane which
which is here which is getting sort of
more and more residential so potentially
that would be a good advantage to be
able to access this site for the hdvs
not Riot population
uh but that's only a potential
again this shows it with the Landscaping
so there is some existing Landscaping
along the A14 but there's proposals for
a bit more
and then a little bit um and then some
existing landscape and some more
Landscaping along the
um London Road and around the dwellings
and you can also see the attenuation
basins here so this would be
um undeveloped for the suds
okay so I set out in your report there
has been some archaeology found on the
site so this is trench one here this is
the site where they found the the human
Moraine so that this is sort of the area
where they think the church was site of
the former Church
so if I just go back it's sort of this
area that is of high in high importance
and we have been shown again this is
indicative but a revised plan to show
how it could be set out to retain this
area as sort of
surfacing and parking so that it would
not need to be built on if that's if
that's the decision made in terms of
archeology at the moment they could
choose whether to leave it in situ or
try and remove the the archeology
these are the site photos so this is
from London Road these are the the
houses on London Road and the site is
just beyond there
again this is where we parked for the
site visit so you can see the the site
Beyond and the houses in the foreground
again another one with the site
here
and this is looking down this is the
Footbridge well the bridge over to the
park and ride site so you can see this
is the existing
um footpath and cycle path from London
Road and it would cross over sort of
sort of disappear or behind underneath
the bridge and then the new
um pedestrian path would go up here
so this is looking towards into the park
and ride so this here this access at the
moment which is sort of the One Way Out
this would become two ways and lead to
the the new development
and this would become a junction off it
for the park at the buses and the cars
to the park and ride and then again they
would swing around and then join this
um two-way road again so this would be
the access and some of this Landscaping
would be lost
um because this would need to be widened
and changed in alignment
again this is the roundabout so these
are the retail units so this would be
removed there would this there would be
a two-way Road and a junction off this
way to the retail units
and so these are within the site see the
A14 along here this is looking back
towards uh the retail units at copdock
and Tesco
yeah those are the houses So currently
they've got a view onto the site but
there would be Landscaping along here
again this is the current Thompson and
Morgan sort of overflow car park and the
development would sort of swing around
there
and yeah this is looking up towards
Thompson and Morgan you can just see
their their buildings their low uh line
buildings at the top of the hill
let's see how far it slopes
again looking back this is uh Tesco and
the retail units
this is uh looking up again towards
Thompson and Morgan here
in a popular Lane and this is looking
across the site
um sort of a long distance View and so
copdock is copdock interchanges here
and that's photos so
in conclusion
um a set out in your report the
development is broadly in line with the
development plan and is considered
acceptable in relation to neighbor
immunity while there will be an impact
on the highway Network it's it's not
being considered severe as as to justify
the refusal of planning permission and
therefore the recommendation is as set
out on your report to approve subject to
conditions thank you
thank you Elizabeth
questions for the officer
Council Busby
yeah we've got an employment site
adjacent to the one that we're looking
at today the one that was part of the
Water Grange development and they've
spent a fair amount of money putting a
new entrance in there
wasn't that considered as a better
entrance for this site rather than
trying to take it through an extremely
busy retail Park
we have to take applications as they
come to us and this is what the proposed
access is so they never propose an
access via the other site I don't know
whether that was to do with land
ownership but this is the access of what
we've been shown and it's been
considered acceptable by the highway
Authority
councilman
well I was going to bring up Mr chairman
that the same uh point there with the
with the junction uh we're talking about
something that is hasn't happened at all
on this industrial site yet and let the
traffic lights and the full scope of the
junction alterations to access it have
been put in place and yet changes to
Lanes at the scrivener drive roundabout
have not yet been implemented or don't
have to be implemented yet does that
show us what the highways
Authority alike and also within the
report it does mention that National
highways stated that development will
contribute to queues along the western
approach slip roads to the cop talk
interchange they have therefore
requested a condition requiring a scheme
of warning lights sorry warning signs to
State cues likely on road ahead where
are they going to put those about 200
yards from The Junction because that's
what they usually do along the a12 all
the Junctions all the signs warning of
congestion ahead are beyond the last
possible point where you can get off to
avoid it
so in other words you're into cuboids
this is why you're in the queue not we
could have told you beforehand why you
weren't going to be there so are we
gonna is there any suggestions to where
those signs should be
no there is there it would be a
condition to approve where those signs
would go so I can't say where they would
go some point before before that a
junction or on that Junction
put that in the same sort of category as
smart motorways do we
we wait until the May occurs first
Maybe
highways officer can help you
[Music]
um
I cannot speak
ing on the
Trunk Road
and it's subject to and in condition the
location and the sign
be agreed with
National highways
thank you
any more questions for Elizabeth
carry on
now
okay have you have you produced a uh a
model
potential traffic flows in the future
which take into account the 1200 new
homes that wallsey Grange the 150 houses
and uh at belstead a 600 houses at
Hadley Toys R Us mothercare coming back
uh the Wolsey Grange employment sites
500 houses at Great Blake and have you
have you put that all into a model for
the [ __ ] dock interchange and the Tesco
roundabout and scrivener roundabout
um yes this this this this was provided
by by the applicant in the transport
assessment
those things were taken into account
were they not just the extra 500
vehicles
plus all of the arctics and the vans
that are going to go onto the site as
well I mean we're probably talking about
what upwards of maybe up to 2 000
vehicle movements to and from that site
in a day
that's an addition in addition to roads
that are already
clogged
so I can't see how it can't have an
impact
at your question
well we considered that it it would have
a significant impact but
but not a
severe impact
um which which in terms of numbers means
um the impact from this proposed list is
generally not
greater than than five percent of
all the traffic that I think those
Freedom through the junction
five if you're at 60 of what the
junction can take but if you're up to 99
or 110 an extra five percent is is
significant as you said
severe and it could be significant I
mean you've heard of the straw that
broke the camel's back haven't you I
mean I quite frankly I would want I want
to see this model
the of these Junctions as the traffic
flows through these two Junctions
because I can't believe that anybody
could come up with the fact that it
can't make a significant impact on it
2 000 extra vehicle movements per day
be at rush hour
through those Junctions it can't cope
with what they've got at the moment
essentially that was not a really good
question and that you'll bring this all
up in debate well the question was am I
able to see the the model the shows that
all of these things have been taken into
account
there we go we don't have there isn't a
copy of the model on the slide so no I
can't show you a model
no
no more questions
fine
we'll move on
I will now invite the parish council
represent to speak Mr Peter Powell
am I on yeah you are
good morning chair good morning
committee Peter Powers Broughton Parish
Council
four locally designated Wildlife sites
may be affected by this application with
41 of UK species lost since 1970s these
sites are precious
Wildlife sites are complex ecosystems of
interdependent microorganisms plants and
Wildlife including large mammals like
deer when links between Wildlife sites
and wider Countryside are severed they
become genetically isolated population
Islands leading to interbreeding
depression and a breakdown of that
ecosystem Haven's Gateway highlighted
such a length that runs past and through
this application this is incorporated
into baber's own 2012 development
framework report covering Ipswich brings
development at Pages 34 to 36 so we
dispute the biodiversity gain quoted at
7-4 of your committee report as it
ignores biodiversity diversity loss on
this link
and we are surprised by the comments
about deer on page 23 which are out of
context and disregard completely the
issues we have raised now and in our
formal submission that have been ignored
in this report
but this is an easy fix
a condition to ensure the boundaries of
the site utilize head rows or fences
with Wildlife gaps to accommodate this
Wildlife movement will address this
issue
we welcome the revised Building height
of 12.5 meters and the suggestion that
there will be a 15 meter green buffer
between the adjacent homes and the
commercial buildings so can a condition
be included to ensure this buffer
we are concerned about the proposed
noise limit of 5 DB above background for
the development a nighttime limit of 38
DB would be a significant nuisance and a
potential health impact for residents
we would recommend the condition should
be for no increase over background
levels at residences at night with a
duty to measure an if appropriate
retrospectively mitigate if that is not
achieved
this decision to consider as a reserve
matter the site's sustainable
credentials fall short of current
opinion on the need for renewable energy
and Energy Efficiency measures such as
solar panels PV cells battery storage
Wayne water capture and gray water
recycling were of little significance
when cs7 gained approval but these are
now part of our neighborhood plan which
was submitted to baber on the 4th of
November
we would ask the committee to require
that all Reserve matters come back
before the planning committee so that
these matters are subjected to critical
consideration
traffic this does concern us but the
issues are extensively covered by others
however we do question the outcome if
the cop.in interchange upgrade plan
doesn't happen
we agree with the recommendations of the
archaeological officer if you're of a
mind to approve this application we
would ask you to consider our
suggestions to address the issues we
have raised
thank you very much for remain there
we'll see whether there's any questions
for you
thanks McGraw
good morning thanks very much for coming
um from from your comments it seems that
the slight modification to the original
comments made by the parish council's
objections that you're fundamentally and
I just want to check I've got this right
that you're fundamentally
um still objecting as long as the you
want conditions to be met is that
correct am I reading what you're saying
here that those that you've got a list
of conditions that you believe would
make this acceptable is that a fair
statement
we are still concerned about it
particularly in relation to the traffic
um I think being realistic we realize
that this site is going to come forward
as some form of
application and
whether it is a commercial or
residential it's going to come forward
in somewhere rather we just want to make
sure it comes forward that some
important issues are addressed
you mentioned in one of your comments
about Wildlife corridors and I noticed
the report contains some information
about the well relative undesirability
of Mount Jack dear an invasive species
which I know to my cost
um do like Crossing roads and running
into things and obviously you've got
some significant traffic in the area the
mud jack could be more of a problem than
uh than um can I say a wildlife game
uh
Chantry vial from my experience has roe
deer
Chinese water deer
Mount Jackson the most popular pretty
much they've become very invasive across
the country so they are they are there
and I have seen fallow there
it's most nearly all the deer in the UK
apart from Red Deer and roe deer which
we have are invasive species
the other four are all invasive species
they're a bit like squirrels
but they still are part of the
ecosystems of all those those four
different Wildlife areas so you take
them out of it and for instance much act
years eat a lot of brambles they're
they're very they like eating brambles
they keep the brambles down so when
you've got a wildlife area they're
actually contribute to it
um
and if you stop Munchak deer going
through that
Wildlife Corridor which allows them to
go down through and underneath the
underpass under the A14 they will simply
cross the A14 so stopping them going
through that way is going to increase
the number of number of
deer collisions and just finally if I
could ask just yes that's fair point and
finally if I could just ask that there's
a number of conditions have been added
to the recommendation
um I believe I'm not certain but I think
most of those cover points you raised in
your presentation or they can be
addressed or they can be used to address
the concerns you've raised here yes for
instance I think the height
is
um
the height is going to be a condition
but the buffer isn't so we'd like to see
the buffer added to it so we make sure
that that buffer so that would be the
Principal emission from the conditions
listed in the recommendation I think I
can't remember what on the
recommendation is that I'm sure officers
will pick up on that I think
the noise we're concerned about noise
because I think the recommendation into
the noise
assessment was 5 DB above
and I think the uh environmental
officers
commented that if you put 5D above and
then you have creep which is where you
have a lot of people five of the above
that it becomes great 38 DB is very
close to 40 DB of nighttime noise which
is where you start to have problems with
you can actually start to create health
problems so it seems to me that 38 DB
at those residences could be a health
problem of getting close
so we felt that there shouldn't they
should like I think was in the case of
sort of an Enterprise Park the
recommendation was that the noise level
should be shouldn't be above the present
noise level
thanks very much um perhaps I can ask
the applicant on that question later
okay thank you
have your own response Elizabeth to
comment there
um yeah I don't think
um adding there would be any issue with
adding a landscaping condition that a
minimum of a 15 meter landscape buffer
around the dwellings on London Road
could be included
including that will be a problem thank
you a big problem
very good
um there was what's the other thing
um
thank you Mr Powell well
okay we're
we're okay if you would talk to the
officer
any more questions
no and thank you very much
we have no objector but we do have
um the app the Asians for us and we have
three members of the agents team
um would you like to introduce
yourselves as you start speaking as you
address the committee
chair and members of the committee I'm
Maureen Derry I'm planning agent
age opportunity to speak the principle
of development of this site is
established by its allocation and extant
policy cs7 in the adopted course
strategy there's a demonstrable need for
employment related development
interchange 55 will deliver in excess of
500 full-time jobs in an accessible and
sustainable location
the site would be developed around the
constraints of the overhead lines as a
series of buildings or one single
building to be determined through
Reserve matter applications
final arrangements for addressing the
site's archeology would also be
determined at that stage as agreed with
the county archaeologist we have agreed
a reduction in height of the tallest
buildings to a maximum of 12.5 meters a
landscape buffer and noise levels all of
which we agree can be controlled by
planning condition we respectfully
request that permission is granted in
accordance with your officer's
recommendation
hello my name is Aiden Fisher I'm a
principal transport planner at create
Consulting Engineers with eight years
experience in the field of Transport
planning I've been involved in this
project since 2018 and have worked in
close consultation with both SEC and
National highways as the highways
authorities to provide all the
information required in order for
judgment to be passed in this
application following this consultation
period both SEC and National highways
have concluded that the proposed
development's impact on the highway
would not be severe and therefore in
accordance with the nppf development
would have an acceptable level of impact
on the highway it should also be noted
that this site was assessed on the local
network as part of the water range one
application for a more traffic intensive
office scheme and the principal
development was accepted there were no
safety concerns with proposed access
strategy the site is well located in
regards to sustainable ways of Transport
with excellent Footwear cycleway
connectivity to the surrounding
residential areas as well as being
situated next to Park and Ride with
close
um close to Tesco bus stops in
conclusion with production of the
conditions proposed there are no Harrows
issues that should prevent this
development from being granted a
Planning Commission
in Partnerships with joint applicants
and involved in delivery of the scheme
I think everybody is aware that there
are a shortage of employment sites
across the Eastern region
certainly a shortage in baber and for
the area running from the
this site all the way across to buryson
Edmonds
and there's a specific demand from the
Orwell bridge to Barrison Edmonds that
needs to be fulfilled through planning
delivery
this site has not been marketed we will
we will start marketing after planning
permission is granted if if that is what
you decide today
but however we still have occupiers have
come forward for more land than we have
available on this site we've also had an
occupier who
was looking to tie up land in in Spring
this year had to go to another site
adjacent to Ipswich in order to fulfill
that requirement and that was for about
four acres
um uh we thank you very much
you've obviously run out of time
are there any questions for the
applicants
councilor Baron
um just following on from the last
speaker
it does seem that there is a a
requirement for this
type of employment land within the baby
District
which is clearly demonstrated but I
think by your last comments that you uh
um virtually almost pre-lit if that
would be the case could you just expand
that please
foreign
we have been approached
through our agent sales
and we have uh interest inside
for heads of terms virtually agreed on
wine occupier awaiting authorization
from their head office to go ahead and
two other occupiers coming forward
who
want to engage with this one's planning
permission is in place
so
um as with many commercial sites uh the
trigger on uh on going forward for the
commercial occupiaries can they get
planning and what's the time scale
just a follow-up so are you anticipating
that
um you would be back to us fairly soon
with Reserve matters on this side
for the actual layout
um bear in mind that you seem to be able
to go in a hints of terms position with
potential tenants
our program is
[Music]
um
tying up heads of terms with occupiers
and legal contract
to install access in 2023
you'll appreciate the accesses through
the park and ride and you need to get
the access before you get to the
occupiers land and then occupies
buildings and units constructed in 2024
and occupied in 2024. so the long stop
date for completion of the whole other
side is 2025 but we expect to better
that
foreign
why the access through the park and ride
site and not via the existing access
that's been put in place for the stage
of uh Halsey Grange
two reasons uh really firstly land
ownership
which means that the
um the two sides will come forward at
different times and therefore you have
to rely on the other site to get access
when we know that occupies are there the
second is for the direct route onto the
highway network is through the park and
ride we had we have had discussions with
Suffolk Highway uh Suffolk highways
about that route and agreed it but we've
also agreed with Suffolk County Council
as part of this scheme to provide them a
site for a 30 000 square foot Warehouse
so that they could look at the possible
relocation of some of their facilities
in Ipswich uh to a storage unit on the
edge of town and therefore better use
other facilities so there are a couple
of drivers as to why we um we access
through the park and ride indirect to
the scrivener's day Lane
red so in actual fact
the Woolsey Grange access would be with
two owners
yourselves and
the owners of Aussie Grange accessed via
the park and ride is with two owners
yourself and Suffolk County Council
but you've managed to persuade one of
the owners that by supplying them with
the dirty great big Warehouse that they
would let you through their land whereas
we don't know what's happening to the
units on the Woolsey grain site at the
moment
it's not the most direct route through
the through the park and ride site
because it it comes out to a little
roundabout then comes out to another
roundabout whereas the access from
through wallsey Grange comes to some
traffic lights and then down to a
roundabout and then away probably a much
more much safer and more practical route
so why do you actually still persist
with going through the park and ride
as as um or described the route for uh
commercial traffic is is more or less a
straight route as opposed to gain to
through two dog legs to get through
um uh the Woolsey grains one site
um and
um and Suffolk County Council
were happy to agree uh a route that
allows for them to have other
alternatives for their property
portfolio that it's accommodated by
having a warehouse on site
Council Busby you had a question
thank you
councilman mccrroll
so uh returning to some earlier matters
and I don't know who wants to take this
one
um what contact have you as applicant
had with the surrounding parish councils
and can you address the concerns that
they've raised those already mentioned
in the proposed Rec conditions and those
perhaps not I just wondered if you could
comment on that that point
yes thank you for the question yes we
did have a meeting with
um support and Parish Council uh before
we submitted the planning application so
we were aware of of some of the concerns
that had been raised um by the council
and and to come board what we could in
the in the application documentation
in terms of the planning conditions
um we'd be happy with the addition of
the the conditions that were suggested
um by the parish council in respect of
the landscape
offer I think we just need to look or we
haven't got our noise consultant with us
today we just need to look in detail at
the noise
um the proposed noise condition but the
environmental health officer was was can
didn't raise any objection and has
specified the condition in their
response yeah the noise level was
something I was coming to so if it is
referred to in the in the
recommendations and I'm just just
wanting to know if it's going to be
possible for planning officers to be
able to take on the parish council
objections with the applicant and see if
those can be included in the conditions
this is still to me it seems there's
parts of this application there are
still a little bit under
and there's still some way to go if
that's a fair point to them but yes I
would say I would say that we've we've
found out obviously all of the
King from the the consultees
um we will be having a discussion with
the case officer about those
um there's certainly a lot of conditions
in there that are pre-commencement
conditions that we would be be seeking
to to remove as many of those as
possible because what we want to do with
it being a hybrid application is to be
able to get on site as quickly as
possible to build the access without
being frustrated by pre-commencement
conditions but we will be having a a
very detailed
um look at the conditions as just as
soon as we're able after committee
and that would seem to be the big one
the access the roundabout whoever does
the roundabout whether it's associated
with the Woolsey Grange application or
if it defaults to being associated with
this application
is there any Security in the
arrangements to make sure that that is
in place but it's going to have to be in
place frankly for any work to be done
I'd have thought
let's go back to the poem sorry what
we're suggesting is that if it hasn't
been built by the Woolsey Grange
application which would be for the 300th
dwelling then after 25
of the developable area has been
occupied the for this application The
Works would have to be done
we can't request it before they start
because that would be unfair so it has
to you know we have to allow some
development before we ask them to do the
works so it's 25 of this application not
Woolsey Grange no so it would be
either the 300 houses come first in
which case was the grange will build it
or if they if that stalls for whatever
reason and then this development you
know goes really quickly and they get to
their 25 they would need to come in to
to sort to do the scriven to drive
proposals I might be being a bit stupid
probably is but
when the Woolsey Grange have to supply
when they've built their 300th dwelling
so at completion of 300 dwellings yes
and how far on are they now we don't
know but I so I I can't say that it
seems to me a limiting factor we might
have to default to to this application
to provide the roundabout which looks
like it's going to be essential
thank you
Pastor McLaren you were looking no or am
I no councilor Barrett that bro
catch the beer sorry yes
um sorry
um I think my question was asked I
wanted to know what what state Wolseley
games had got to but you've said you
don't know but um you think it's round
about the 200th but uh being useful if
we did know
um because we could then Somali as well
perhaps in another seven eight months
they might be at the 300th and we'd know
sooner but uh I accept if the officer
hasn't got that information
that would have been helpful
the further question I'm not sure
whether it's for the for the officer or
for the for the applicant really uh and
that is upon uh what evidence has been
sort of submitted concerning employment
need because Ipswich Borough Council in
their comments within the report have
raised considerable concerns over the
amount of available Lambda is already in
the Ipswich area and the surrounding
area and yet you the applicant has
stated that there is a need for
employment land whereas there's 20 odd
Acres already existing with permissions
at various places around Ipswich
not counting up the A14 corridor
do you have any comment oh just just a
quick comment so um we presented
evidence
Greta Norwich local plan examination in
respect of the demand on the A14
Corridor and we um we worked with
travels to prepare a paper on that that
paper was submitted as an appendix to
our planning statement for this
application which was basically showing
that the demand for shed spatial on the
A14 was growing exponentially and that
the other employment areas in the
locality would basically have run out of
consented capacity within 36 months and
that that report was done in 2021 so
it's we're coming quite close to the to
those 36
months
I think Maureen said Norwich when she
met Ipswich
but yes there's that between the oral
region uh and Barrison Evans there's
a local plan allocation of about 3
million square feet
um there's perceived demand to probably
another million and a half square feet
above that
and Mark has changed substantially
because in in East Anglia
until about two years ago there was
never a million square foot building
closest one was Peterborough we've now
seen close to that at bearson Evans and
recently you'll be aware
of consent detail consent for the range
for one million 1.2 million square feet
at Gateway 14.
so there is huge demand in this area
and there isn't sufficient allocations
currently in the local plans
thank you
any more questions
thank you very much
moving on
um we have statements from the two award
members uh going in alphabetical order
councilor hardiker player you have
thank you chair
I will not be able to attend the meeting
in person but offer the comments below
I've checked this application as it
currently stands my primary concern with
this development is access I live very
close by and so I'm very familiar with
the roads Pavements roundabouts and
Junctions of this area because I
regularly shop at Tesco and occasionally
walk to b m or Pizza Hut I do not
believe that the retail Park is a
suitable way of accessing the site and
while I know that highways have also
raised the issue of walking cycling
access I'd like to point out that the
footpath at the park and ride end is
very narrow and overgrown and that cycle
access to the retail Park in general is
essentially zero
I'd much rather see some cooperation
between landowners and have this site
connected to the main road Network by
the new traffic light control Junction
just up the a1214 behind Audi the spur
from it arcs round and points directly
at the proposed site for this
development ending less than 200 meters
away
the alternative layout of the proposed
plan submitted by the applicant would
not need to change to accommodate this
either as a close Road between units two
and three would link nicely with this
access road too
the original proposed Access Road could
then be much smaller in scope and become
a cycle pedestrian link to the park and
ride and Retail Park and the newly
proposed walking cycling link to the
a1214 would not be required preserving
The Greenery there that counselor Rick
hardaker
thank you we also have a statement from
councilor Zach Norman
unfortunately can't attend the meeting
but I would like to make the following
representation regarding Wildlife
corridors and also green energy
it's essential that all developments
along this Corridor must take care and
preserve the existing Wildlife corridors
as in reality being able to create new
Wildlife corridors are not going to be
as efficient established or as
environmentally friendly as the wildlife
corridor already in place I would like
to see in the planning conditions of
this application something that enhances
the wildlife corridors so that we don't
see these eroded
in addition I would also like to see a
condition on this application
surrounding solar panels we have
applications all across baber that where
it is proposed that Fields be ripped in
half to put in huge numbers of solar
panels which is an appear to be a green
measure but actually destroys the
already natural environment there and is
not a sustainable measure of reaching
our environmental goals as a council
I would like to see that on the
employment building solar panels are
Incorporated on the roof so that cat
power can be provided in this way so
that it's not destroying a field but
rather would enhance this scheme so that
the scheme can be feature proved and can
provide something positive to the area
and help us as a council achieve our
goals of becoming Net Zero
I feel that both of these requests are
reasonable and any company wants to take
on a scheme of providing employment is
inherently a good thing as is something
that is needed across this District but
these schemes could also benefit the
district in other ways and we as a
council can see to be leading on this to
set us ahead of other councils and
provide excellent schemes that not only
provide jobs but also benefits to the
environment so that the environmental
loss of providing such schemes can at
least show some positives I hope that
these points can be delivered to the
planning committee and are taken into
consideration when confirm coming to a
determination
there
fine we are now
after that as we can't question them
moving into debate
go on Council advice but you kickoff
okay I find this
Highway seem a bit suspicious if we if
we look at the highways comment in
August of this year
they required a contribution towards
sustainable travel improvements on the
1214 London Road Corridor further
encourage the use of sustainable modes
of travel and mitigate the impact of the
development of the local Highway Network
so not necessarily talking about
improving a junction or the roundabout
we're talking about alternative means of
transport
a contribution of 124 000 is required
without this contribution The Proposal
would not be in accordance with
nppf-111 due to a severe your words due
to a severe cumulative impact upon the
highway Network
okay so two months later
they're persuaded that they don't need
this development this contribution
because the changes to the roundabout
are going to happen as part of Aussie
Grange
and I mentioned about how the they're
going to cope with changing the habits
of people to get off cars and into bikes
and walking
which was where the contribution was for
quote it is noted that the proposal will
be providing a significant investment in
off-site Highway improvements
not certain I've seen any of those
that will also benefit users of the
proposals and others
not convinced that this is the rights
solution
for this particular site
I think we all want to see some
employment on it it's a good site for
that not a problem with that
you have to take account of the issues
that we've got
and
it's going to be marginally better for
the transport for the traffic to come
out of the wallsey Grange new entrance
than to come through a retail Park I
know you haven't got access that way yet
but
I think
we've got to investigate that and I
would propose that we defer this until
we've had the opportunity to talk to
Taylor wimpy about access through that
particular field
uh and until we we can see the the
traffic model that shows that the
Junctions can take the additional
traffic because again it says in here
that's
uh
it's severe these there's
the quote um
the Junctions are capacity
you can't increase capacity whatever you
do
well if they're already at capacity
who already
to some extent an over capacity and we
whatever time of day you go along there
you can guarantee there's going to be
cues between 7 30 and 9 30 in the
morning
four to six four to six thirty in the
evening you can hardly move
so if they're at capacity where the
hell's that extra traffic going to go I
would like to see the traffic model that
shows that those Junctions can cope
extra
potentially 2 000 movements a day so
I haven't got not got a problem with
using that site for employment I think
it's a good a good site for that I'm
just concerned that we don't make it
more difficult for everybody else in the
area particularly in Pinewood who can't
get off Pinewood at the moment
through scrivener Drive
that we investigate all possible
opportunities to find a different way
out so
I'm suggesting that we defer until we've
conducted those investigations
for referral
okay do we have a second there
comes to Jameson
uh you're happy to second I Echo
councilor Busby's words I use that
Junction quite often and um it is a
nightmare at the moment so so what it'll
be like with
more private movements I don't know but
um yeah I'm happy to
proposal that we defer and look at
alternative access methods
thank you
there's a way like to debate this before
cancer
thank you Mr chairman yes I I'd support
this this deferral because there are so
many holes in the potential traffic
implications of this site
um it makes you wonder just sort of what
quite what is going on
um the everything's a little bit vague
when it comes to signage by national
highways we know that National highways
have a proposal in to upgrade the cop
Doc Bill interchange if there's some
funding to be available but it's not
likely to be available until
2025 onwards
even if it is approved and with the
present climate as far as finances of
the country are concerned I suspect that
it won't get approval which means it
will be stuck again back in 2008 the
parts of the a12 leading up to got doc
were operating at capacity and we've had
considerable buildings since that time
so there's far too many travel impacts
in this area I'm also a little bit
concerned by the
rather Bland statement of uh
archaeological conditions to cover
what's going to happen to the this site
of the church and the graveyard if
they're going to remove
uh skeletons from there they are going
to have to get a license from the
home office to move them and if they're
not they're just going to sort of tarmac
over the top and treat it as part of a
car park are we ending up with another
Richard III type situation
um
so it's um it's it's a site that perhaps
needs a little bit more recognition a
little bit more
sympathetic consideration that is being
proposed at the moment
uh Mr chairman I'm really concerned that
when applications are coming to the
council and coming to committee to be
decided on that then uh when we've been
actually questioning the highways
Authority and they have told us in no
uncertain terms that they are happy with
what we've got before us that we do not
take that at face value and then we are
deferring when uh this is already taken
quite a long time to get to this
position I think this is unacceptable to
one the applicant and I think it doesn't
show a very good light on the committee
of not being able to make a decision
based on the information that has
clearly been laid before us and what
we're asking is saying I don't believe
the information before us I want to see
that information anything but surely we
have to take the information from our
professional offices
face value we can't be asking for this
further information delaying a process
which is taken presumably a long while
to get to this stage I think it's unfair
the applicant and it shows a lack of us
judgment I think we need to believe what
we're told
otherwise where do we stop
do we then look at everything in my
detail I think it's very irresponsible
for this committee to defer decisions
that is here to decide on
okay I'll respond to that if we didn't
question things then there'd be no point
in anything coming to committee because
the if everything is decided by the
officers and the words are perfect the
committee have no role I
okay I come back on that I don't have a
problem with questioning things but
there's questioning things getting
answers and then not believing without
what you're being told and that's
basically where you are I think
councilman
three terms in the in the report from
the offices
thank you
Ashley mcroll you wish to make a comment
yeah um I mean for debate descends I
just think that there's a couple of
points I'd make one is that yes I take
the point about highways officers they
um piece on the um impact except in one
occasion it's less than five percent I'd
like to know if there's one occasion is
less than five percent impact not severe
how severe is it is it 10 or 15 because
you've given a figure for it for one
thing you're saying all but one part is
five percent second thing is I think on
the archaeological
um side I've got a feeling that the
proposal is in fact to preserve the site
intact it's not to actually excavate the
bodies that's pointed out in the report
and that's not uncommon basically there
are unknown numbers of graveyards across
England and Wales that are going to be
covered for centuries to come and not
all of them are going to be significant
but um and so enough what you often do
is you preserve them
actually literally under car Parks it's
almost preservation it's also it's a
preservation technique sometimes used to
keep sites intact as long as you know
that what you're doing you're putting it
on top
um I I don't think we have the right
to differ I think it's probably not the
right thing to do given that we are
taking professional advice
thank you
councilor hope you will
share that
um point that I don't think is
appropriate for us to be looking to
defer this application we've got all the
professional advice in front of us and
yes we can question it which we have and
we've had answers
um no doubt this is an extremely busy uh
Junction and um it will have increased
traffic moves because of this but the
answers have been given the arguments
have been put forward by highways and
all the other authorities who are
responsible for it and it seems rather
inappropriate for us to go against that
um the other thing that I I would
question is is councilor Busby's reason
for a deferral was to instruct the
applicant to go and talk to a different
landowner to try and get his application
through was that the wording of it
because to me if you're deferring it to
get further details about
um traffic movements and and asking for
technical uh evidence and advice from
highways in addition to what we've
already been given and heard then I
could sort of Have A Little Bit of
Sympathy with deferring but if you're
just telling the applicant to go and
talk to someone else to try and make a
better scheme that suits you then I
don't agree with that phrasing and
that's what it came across as
thank you
Council I don't know if the transport
officer could answer the question I
briefly referred to about the which what
is the level which is above five percent
and where is it what what percentage
would that one be
is to inform the committee
well I think it would just just be a
case of it eating
the five percent which is the typical
threshold the the he would
to be a
yes are we saying a little over a lot
over well you know it was
five percent so even if it was six week
we could
object I think but um it's worth noting
that the scriven road
roundabout has could
that's the issue without this
how is it it's adding to the the
congestion to these shoes but
it
it would would still have exactness a
H about this proposal
thank you
thank you chair
um
in this day and age of
um
businesses and um
are
budgets and things like that
um being changeable I think any offer
of providing employment
is important and it's important that
labor District Council
to encourage employment this is going to
provide I think you said 500
um
jobs
I think whatever happens on the A14 and
off the A14 whichever Junction you
choose is going to have its limitations
because it's already in place
clothes and everything so it is going to
link but I think it's important for our
district to encourage as much business
as possible
so I shall be supporting the
correct uh yes Mr chairman I thought
you've forgot me but uh but anyway
um no uh I agree with the three previous
speakers
um that uh we shouldn't defer this we we
have a duty to to get this sorted and we
should bear in mind
we should bear in mind uh the fact that
you know the government is going for
growth we we do need growth we do need
employment and that is important and we
shouldn't delay that
um I think perhaps um councilors
possibly does have some
um concern and points but the highway
officers and we're always told they're
the experts a new councilor Busby and I
and perhaps others know what we think of
some of these experts but there we are
so we've got to accept what they're
saying and
um I I certainly will not support the
deferment thank you
right is there anything more to add to
to well I've just suggest um I mean we
haven't got a proposal in front of us
for actually approving the application
which I'm prepared to do so we need to
go to the motion and then substantive so
we do need a proposal so what I'm
proposing is that we accept the
application as it is before us and I
called for a second for that because
obviously we need to take the first vote
first and then obviously if that passes
then we don't need to do this second
vote do we sorry I'm not trying to do a
job but it just seems a logical step
what we are going to take is going we
have the motion for deferment and we
have a proposal in the second year we
will take that and vote on it then when
we come back you may if you wish propose
accepted
let's do the vote first
and we'll come back
now in progress so this is a vote for
deferral of the application
uh Council of beer can I take you away I
am against the
[Music]
councilor okay
thank you members so we have four votes
for deferral
and seven votes against deferral
so that motion has failed
yes you can thank you I propose that we
uh accept the officer's recommendation
for approval and uh we call for a second
for that
councilor hold thank you
as an authority we should welcome this
application for employment plan coming
forward
I note the concerns about transport but
I certainly will second this proposal
[Music]
thank you we have a proposal a second or
anybody wish to comment councilman
I'd be happy to support that but I would
like the inclusion of the wildlife
corridorah suggested if that's something
between the applicant
and the officers and the as the
suggestion that came from Spartan Parish
Council and other parties so I'd like
that added if the proposer and seconder
were happy
thank you also I know that particular
Corridor quite well because the ones
proposed is to go into the old London
Road and join up those two areas of land
across the A14 I use that route quite
frequently on the on a bicycle funnily
enough uh on the cycle path on the
underpass uh because it's a very safe
way to get into the north of Ipswich
down the cycle past down London Road if
anybody wants to know
thank you
councilor Osborne
thank you Mr chairman yes I'm happy to
support
um what Aleister McCall has said and
have that added if if it's possible to
the conditions of of the wildlife
Corridor thank you
thank you any more comments before we go
to a vote
no okay
we just confirm officers have got that
that's been accepted by the proposer and
secondary stuff
um but the case office just reminded me
there was one about a landscaping buffer
as well
two conditions Landscaping puffer and
Wildlife corridor
okay another two
you're happy
thank you
I said this vote now for approval is in
progress councilor bear
approve the application thank you
Council
okay
thank you members so that is seven votes
four and four votes against therefore
that is okay thank you very much
the next meeting will be on the 30th of
November here in the council chamber
and former closed the meeting with
thanks to all of you who tried to help
me as we went along thank